small milestone in Germany today as the
first flows of liquefied natural gas
have entered the country's gas Network
it's happening via VIA a new LNG
terminal the country's first and
courtesy of this ship the hug Esperanza
lovely name it's all Happening Here in
wilhelm's hoffen on Germany's North Co
North Sea Coast that's where the ship
the central part of the terminal will
convert the delivered LNG back to its
gaseous state
and the floating terminal in wilhelms
Haven is connected to the Natural Gas
Network in Germany via a 26 kilometer
Pipeline and the pipeline costs around
150 million euros and can deliver around
six percent of Germany's natural gas
supply needed in a year right now it's
just in test phase full operation is
expected in January
let's learn more about this with Mikhail
Stan he's Professor for energy storage
and energy systems at the Technical
University oth Regensburg Mikhail great
to have you on the show uh first flows
we've had multiple Milestones with this
terminal the fact it was completed uh
now we have a ship that's there and now
we have the first flows going in give us
some sense of how important this
actually is for where we are in this
crisis
it's definitely very meaningful to
Germany as we really struggle to get
more independent from Russian energy
Imports so that's definitely Milestone
and and I'm really happy that it
happened that fast but yeah that's
bridging us for some years but it's not
the final solution definitely
it also um there's also going to be
issues getting gas on the open markets I
imagine this doesn't necessarily solve
that does it the price of gas as we've
seen can be very erratic
yeah it's that's definitely uh the case
because
um the competition is quite high on gas
and gas supply and so this gives us an
opportunity to have more access to
liquid natural gas markets which we
didn't have so far because we were so
reluctant on this toxic cheap energy
from Russia but uh it it's really so so
from the environment environmental point
of view it's not the best case but
um in terms of economy of course we need
this independency in Supply security
that's why it's an important step for
Germany you mentioned the environmental
aspect natural gas has always been part
of the plan to move to Renewables it was
supposed to be a bridging uh fuel does
the construction of all of these LNG
terminals there are multiple that are
going to be constructed some are almost
done right now does this make that
transition more difficult because it
creates this kind of obviously a
terminal for gas or does it make it
easier because some of this
infrastructure can be used for hydrogen
from what I understand
well um we wouldn't have faced out of
fossil energy from from Russia that fast
without this war so definitely it was in
the plan to phase out but not that fast
so it's just substituting here um fossil
energy but of course we have to have the
Frameworks like the emission trading
system in Europe which has just been
extended to heating systems and also
transport
um and and it's it's a bridge but I'm
not in favor of making contracts with
Qatar starting in 26 lasting for 15
years this is really contrary to our
climate goals but you're right
definitely we can use some of that
infrastructure to import renewable
energy so in form of ammonia where we
have 150 habers worldwide many ships we
but it's not fitting for green hydrogen
it would fit for green LNG you can do
green LNG via power to gas and that's
competitive and technically and
economically feasible people compared to
LNG imports from Qatar so we should
definitely look and create new energy
Partnerships which have our values which
really can import then green energy in
whatever form but many molecules energy
in LNG so it's it's definitely doable
and there should be the photo I want to
break in I'm sorry I won't break it I
want to ask you before we run out of
time the approval process and the
construction of this it lasted only 10
months that's light speed by German
regulatory standards
um it's often been said that it'd be
nice to have this for renewable
approvals for winds turbines for solar
cells does this set of precedents
briefly if you can
no it doesn't we have this in
vaccinations if we saw many light speeds
but not in energy transition we
definitely need this for climate action
to accelerate wind and solar and so on
and if you compare it to Corona uh the
money we spent for Kenora Corona would
definitely last uh to have a complete
transition towards climate neutrality
worldwide so that's the good news it
does be feasible and it's doable but we
need acceleration from the permission
site definitely especially for wind
professor at the Technical University
oth Regensburg thank you so much
thank you